[Music]
I'm not gonna be around people that
bring me down on a daily basis so I
cannot cancel and be around too when
you're just a [ __ ] things got super
real on the season 15 premiere of
Keeping Up with the Kardashians so real
that the famous sisters were actually
feuding on Twitter as they live tweeted
the dramatic episodes here's the
backstory Kim and Kourtney got into an
explosive argument on the show Kim made
arrangements for the family Christmas
card photo shoot and Kourtney was
uncooperative how is the person that is
the least busy how many leaves de visite
you're not ever accommodating and
everybody says it the sisters relived
their spat on Twitter
Kourtney tweeted that her priority is
being a mom Kim replied writing and mine
is not the shoot was with our kids my
number one priority is being a mother as
well and I can work too so can you
Chloe even got dragged in and
cryptically wrote to Kourtney do we want
to get into why all of us were
frustrated with you you want to do this
on Twitter in a teaser for next week's
episode looks like we may find out more
Kourtney if you don't care enough fix
relationships dear sister you could boss
do you come over here with
pushes and pushes I'm not up for it
you